so in this video we're going to continue
looking at the worksheet that we started
in the lecture on convection and so I
did two locations in the lecture we did
this one here and this turns out to be a
little thermal with no cloud then we did
this one which turns out to have a cloud
that starts at 8,000 feet and stop
somewhere between ten and eleven
thousand feet and so what I'm gonna do
next is this one over here
so I'll look at the temperature 64 I
compare it to the air that's already up
there which is 53 so first thing to keep
in mind remember what we're comparing
this to what's the temperature of the
air already up there don't confuse
yourself with these numbers that you
already put up there you're going back
to what the air what the temp air
temperatures are all right so I got 64
it's 53 it's gonna rise and so what I'm
gonna do is take 64 and I'm gonna
subtract the dry adiabatic lapse rate
which is five point four I get fifty
eight point six and then I compare over
here it's once warmer than 48 so we're
gonna keep on going
sounds subtract another five point four
which is fifty three point two and
that's warmer than 46 subtract another
five point four that's forty seven point
eight which is warmer than forty three
so I'm gonna keep going
and I get forty two point four which is
one more than forty two so it's gonna
keep on going and so I'm just testing
every thousand feet subtract another
five point four and I get 37 now 37
warmer than 36 but you've got to keep
track of what's happening because that's
also the dew point so as you're doing
this keep checking to see that you you
know you want to make sure you you
realize it if you hit the dew point okay
so as you do these calculations
keep checking down and saying okay my
dewpoints 37 do I hit 37 right there I
do so at this point
okay so right there the temperature is
equal to the dew point therefore we know
that the relative humidity is a hundred
percent all right so now remember what
we said once you are so we're this is
the beginning of the cloud once you have
a cloud then you are instead of
subtracting five point four you're
subtracting in this class two point
seven and the reason for that is because
the addition of latent heat helps keep
the atmosphere warmer than it normally
would be alright so I've got my thirty
seven and then subtract this time two
point seven and that gets me thirty four
point three still warmer there then the
surrounding air so it's gonna rise and
continue to rise a cloud continues to
grow
okay subtract two point seven thirty one
point six okay that's warmer than thirty
so it continues to grow cloud continues
to grow and subtract two point seven
again I get twenty eight point nine okay
now notice here that 31.6 war were the
thirty one twenty eight point nine
almost but not quite twenty nine so what
that tells us is that the cloud will
rise past this point and almost but not
quite get to this point so I want to
draw it to show that it's between those
two lines like that and then where does
the air go well it comes out the top and
sinks back down so I'm gonna draw a few
arrows to show that okay all right so
now let's go to date two so on the
handouts probably on the other side or
the second page and so the set up here
is actually the bottom part is almost
same okay so the conditions down here
are the same and in fact temperatures
down here are the same the only thing
that's changed is we've brought in some
colder air aloft so we've got cold air
that's coming down from the north we're
gonna see how that changes things so the
first thing I'm gonna do is we're gonna
do this location right here so I've got
85 greater than 84 so I know it's gonna
rise subtract 5.4 seventy nine point six
seventy four point two I'm just
subtracting five point four each time
okay so warmer than the air around it
rises warmer than air around it rises
warmer than air rises not warmer than
air around it so somewhere between here
and here that air stops rising and then
sinks back down okay and this is exactly
what we got on day one so this is
exactly the same answer nothing's
changed here no cloud okay why is there
no cloud
we didn't cool it to the dewpoint all
right so let's go to this second one
here
okay so 76 minus five point four seventy
point six five point four sixty five
point two five point four fifty nine
point eight and so I'm just subtracting
five point four here and I'm checking as
I go along to make sure that I'm warmer
than the air around it which I am now
here forty nine we've hit the dew point
okay
so right there temperature so you go to
the dew point and the relative humidity
is a hundred percent okay that's the
that one right there is that is the flat
bottom of our cloud which then is going
to start growing vertically
okay so now remember I'm going to
subtract 2.7 from now on because now I'm
inside a cloud two point seven forty six
point three forty three point six forty
point 938 point two so let me see warmer
than the air around it warmer than the
air around it warmer warmer
so our cloud continues to grow so I'm
gonna keep drawing here thirty five
point five thirty two point eight thirty
point one okay so what we're seeing here
is that the cloud is growing growing
growing growing the air is continuing to
rise so this is what our cloud is doing
roll grow grow I didn't draw it very
straight my cloud is leaning a little
bit but that's because it's hard to use
this whole projector and not be crooked
so here we are at thirty point one and
still warmer than the air around it so
subtract two point seven again I get
twenty seven point four still warmer
than air around it so the cloud just
keeps on going
off the page okay so the point to this
is that this cloud starts in the same
place that it does on day one but
because we've got extra cold air up here
it helps the cloud grow and grow and
grow and grow and grow
alright we'll do the last one here okay
so 64 warmer than 53 so I think 64 point
is five point four fifty eight point six
that's five point four fifty three point
two minus five point four forty seven
point eight minus five point four
42.4 okay now let's just see what we're
doing here
warmer warmer warmer warmer so air is
rising have we hit the dew point we
gotta get down to 37 for the dew point
we haven't got there yet
subtract 5.4 37 okay so there we hit the
dew point so right there
oops off screen here temperature is
equal to the dew point relative humidity
is 100% we get the formation the
beginning of our cloud so then from from
this point forward remember I subtract
two point seven so two point seven is
thirty four point three two point seven
thirty one point six so again I'm
checking warmer warmer warmer
so my cloud is growing and growing
alright so then let's subtract two point
seven twenty eight point nine two point
seven twenty six point two and just like
the other cloud as we go up here we can
see that the temperatures continue to
stay warmer than the surrounding air so
this one like the other one grows off
the page okay so the point two doing all
this was to illustrate that if you want
air to rise to make a cloud the hotter
the air is near the surface the easier
it will rise through the atmosphere
right it's like it's got a better start
the hotter it is but if you made the air
colder up here that also helps air rise
so we can make air rise really high if
we start out really hot or we can make
it rise really high if we make the air
above our heads really cold and so this
is what we're doing here and is causing
the clouds to grow and so what we'll do
in the next lecture is explain well then
what happens
when these clouds keep growing like what
ultimately happens to them okay all
right thanks